>>From the Library of
Congress from Washington DC.
>>Good morning!
I'm Carla Hayden, the
Librarian of Congress and I want
to welcome you to this
very special Story Time
at the Library.
I love reading, don't you?
It's so much fun to let
our imaginations run wild.
We're excited to be teaming
up with Ms. Dolly Parton's
Imagination Library
to introduce you to
some wonderful authors
who will share their
stories with us.
Ms. Parton's work through
her Imagination Library
is awe-inspiring!
She and her team have given
away over 100 million books
to help encourage young readers
like you across the world.
Here at the Library of
Congress we share that passion
for developing young readers!
And we know that the best way
to encourage people like you
to read is to make reading fun!
So that's what we're here to do.
I hope you enjoy
today's story time!
Even more, I hope you keep
reading at home and having fun!
Today, you will warm up
by singing some songs,
touching your toes, and
then get comfortable
and get ready to hear stories.
Now let's get started!
>>Welcome everybody to storytime
and the library of Congress.
We are here in this
beautiful room
and we have a very great story.
I am sorry.
I am not on.
There I am.
Welcome to everyone and everyone
out there on the Internet
to storytime at the Library
of Congress and here we are
in the beautiful Pavilion
and my name is Caroline
and this is Laura Murray, the
author of the gingerbread man.
So today we are going to
start off with our hello,
song and we just need to
learn a little bit of sign.
So in salute for hello,
and then friends is
at the index finger one
way and then the other way,
condom hugging, friends,
hello, friends three times.
Hello, friends and
then it is time --
touch or watch -- to say hello!
Okay? All right.
. Let's go.
Hello, friends, hello,
friends, hello, friends;
it's time to say hello!
(Applause) Good job.
All right.
Let's do our brains.
Open, shut them,
open, shut them,
put them in your lap, lap, lap.
Close them, put them
near your chin, Chin,
open up your little mouths --
let them in -- open, shut them,
open them, shut them, give
a little clap, clap, clap.
Open them, shut them,
open, shut them.
Put them in your lap, lap, lap.
Creep them, call them,
creep them, called them,
right up to your
chin, chin, chin.
Open up your little mouths
and do not let them in.
Yeah! Yeah!
(Applause) All right.
So Laura, can you read us
some of the gingerbread man,
loose on the fire truck? »
LAURA MURRAY: Thank
you, so much.
I am a very excited
person to be here today.
My name is Laura Murray and
I am a children's author
and I also write the
words to the stories.
And my stories are
about a gingerbread man!
And there is a series of them.
The one at that we are going
to read today is the
second in the series.
It is called, "The gingerbread
man, loose on the fire truck"
but before we read
this, you might want
to know why there
is a gingerbread man
on the fire truck?
And it starts with
the very first book.
So a gingerbread man is made
by a classroom full of kids
and he gets to be
part of their class!
And since he is part of their
class, then he gets to go
on field trips with them.
So his first field trip
is to the fire station!
So let's get started!
Now I would like you
to help me if you can.
Would you like to know how?
Okay. We will read a
story in this is our plan.
When I say gingerbread,
you say man!
So let's try it --
gingerbread. »
: Man. » LAURA
MURRAY: Gingerbread. »
MURRAY: You guys got it.
Let's try it with the title.
The gingerbread. »
: Man. » LAURA MURRAY:
Loose on the fire chief --
fire truck by Laura Murray, that
is me because I wrote the words,
illustrated by Michael Lowery.
He drew the what do you think?
The pictures!
The pictures.
Okay. So here we go.
On a bright Monday morning,
my teacher breezed in.
Let's all make a circle.
It's time to begin.
She winked and then whispered,
our field trip's today.
The classroom erupted
with shouts of, "Hooray!
" Very good We're riding the
bus to the big fire station,
to meet firefighters and
Spot, their Dalmatian.
So Sophia leaned down and
said, "You're coming too.
You're our gingerbread man
-- we wouldn't leave you.
Just jump in my backpack,
I'll give you a ride.
There's a pocket for you
over here on the side.
The pocket was cozy.
I peeked from the top.
The bus drove 4 miles then
came to a stop In front
of the building with shiny red
doors stood two firefighters
from Company 4.
One had on gear for
a quick demonstration
and standing beside him
was Spot, the Dalmatian.
That's right.
And the firefighter has
on goggles, a helmet,
and oxygen tank, a flashlight,
an axe, gloves, and boots.
And in Spot the dog!
I was jostled and jiggled
as kids moved about.
Then I fell from the pocket
right on the dog's snout!
Is that a good place for
a gingerbread man to be?
Ohno! Spot sniffed at my
face, taking one sticky lick.
I needed a trick to
get out of there quick!
He tossed me up high
with his mouth open wide,
but I flipped toward his tail
and slid down like a slide.
Weeee! My feet hit the ground.
I took off for the station.
But right on my heels was
that hungry Dalmatian.
I'll run and I'll
dodge, as fast as I can.
I'm not a dog bone!
I'm the gingerbread man!
Very good The class
didn't notice.
They tried on black
boots and helmets,
and air tanks, and
big heavy suits.
Do you see the gingerbread
man there writing?
And who is behind him?
Spot the Dalmatian!
Oh, my goodness!
I dashed to the fire
truck, jumped in a seat.
Whew! I was almost a
sweet doggy treat!.
Wow! He got away I hopped on the
steering will, gave it a spin --
and yelled out, "Honk Honk!"
with a big cookie grin.
The wheel spun past gauges
and switches and knobs --
all kinds of buttons
that do different jobs.
I'll vroom and I'll
zoom, as fast as I can.
I'll steer this big truck,
I'm the gingerbread man!
That is where I am going
to pause for just a minute.
We are going to break the
book up into two sections
and we will do two songs
and then finish the book!
All right!
Okay! All right!
So we need to make
a gingerbread man!
So we are going to go bake,
bake, bake a gingerbread --
add sugar and spice,
and everything nice.
Look! We made our friend.
Okay. One more time.
It is going to be row your boat.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, bake, bake, bake all day,
bake a gingerbread, add spice
and everything nice, look!
We made a friend.
One more time.
Bake, bake, bake all
day, make a gingerbread.
Add sugar and spice and
everything nice, look!
We made a friend!
Yeah! Good job!
(Applause) All right.
Now a classic about a little
boy having an adventure.
We are going to make a
candle with one finger
and then the other is going to
be Jack and he is going to go
up to the candle and he
is going to jump over it.
Okay? Jack be nimble,
Jack be quick,
Jack jump over the candlestick!
All right.
Go the other way.
Jack be nimble, Jack be quick,
Jack jump over the candlestick!
Good job! (Applause) Now
the other half of our story.
Okay. Now let's see what happens
with the gingerbread man.
Does he get away from Spot?
How does he help?
Okay? Then I heard
someone whistle.
Spot trotted away.
So I jumped through the
window without a delay.
I landed on a top of a
big several silver bowl.
Oh, no! I cried out
as I leapt for a pole.
I shimmied right up and I sprang
from the top and then jumped
on a bed with a big belly flop.
Who does belly flops
on their bed?
Anybody? (Laughter) There
were several more bunks
with their covers pulled
tight for each firefighter
who stayed through the night.
I bounced on each bed on my way
to the door, then into a room
with a bright checkered floor.
Where is he going?
I peeked around the corner
and smelled something yummy --
a grumbling sound
rumbled up from my tummy.
I spotted a fireman
filling up bowls
with five-alarm chili
and buttery rolls.
There he is, down Then all of
a sudden I heard a loud noise.
there Woooo!
Fire! One shouted, "No
lunch for us, boys."
They rushed to the bunk
room and slid down the pole.
I followed behind them
then peered down the hole.
Spot wasn't there -- a
sure sign of good luck.
So I slipped down the pole
and then jumped on the truck.
I'll ride to the
rescue, as fast as I can.
I want to help, too!
I'm the gingerbread man!
Weeeee! Can you do that?
Weeeee! went the sirens
the lights flashed around.
As I zoomed past my
classmates below on the ground.
We sped through the streets
and I clung to the back.
near ladders and hoses
piled up in a stack.
There he is The engine pulled
up, firefighters jumped out.
They rushed to the hydrant
and opened the spout.
I spied a large house
with a shed near the back.
Smoke rose from its
window, all sooty and black.
I'll put out that
fire, as fast as I can.
I know I can help!
I'm the gingerbread man!
I grabbed the hose
nozzle and gave it a pull.
But that hose whipped and
bumped like a rodeo bull!.
Because he is so small, is NT?
The water wooshed out and
it doused the old shed.
And the powerful spray
shot the hat off my head.
He lost his hat!
The chief ran up quickly
and dove on the hose.
She crawled her way up
until we came nose to nose.
"Looked everyone!
It's a gingerbread man!
Now where did you come from,"
Said the Fire Chief Anne.
"I came with the children
to visit the station.
But I almost got eaten
by Spot, the Dalmatian.
I had to escape from that
hungry crumb-snatcher,
so I jumped on the truck
when I heard your dispatcher.
" "Good thinking, smart cookie!
We're glad you hopped on.
You wrestled that hose
till the fire was gone.
" Did he help put out the fire?
Yes, he did We packed
up the truck
and drove back to the station.
Can you drive back
to the station?
We pulled in the drive
to a standing ovation.
Can you clap?
(Applause) That is
what innovation means.
Your gingerbread guy
was a brave little man!
"He doused every flame,"
announced Fire Chief Anne
The children applauded
and shouted, "Yeah!
" They held me up high,
yelling, "You saved the day!
" And in the firefighter
said you are really a hero.
You're part of our crew.
But you're missing
your hat so we have one
for you A shiny red
helmet from Company 4!
There are more for
your classmates stacked
up by the door I tried on my
helmet and shouted "Woohoo!
I'm a gingerbread man
and a fireman too!
" And that is the end.
(Applause) You guys did a great
job finding all of the man's
and helping me read that book.
Wow! Nice job!
Very good!
Now we are going to do
a little finger play
and will you show
us how to do it?
Yes. This one is about
five gingerbread men.
Can everyone hold up
their five gingerbread men
and we are going to count down.
Now this has hand
movements to it.
This says five gingerbread
man in a row.
Not going to eat them, no,
no,no, but they looked so sweet
from head to toe ,
crunch, Monch, oh, oh!
If we ate one, how
many do we have left?
4 4 gingerbread men in a row,
not going to eat
them, no, no, no.
But they look so
sweet, from head to toe,
crunch, munch, oh, oh!.
If we have format, we take away
one, how many do we have left?
3. Three gingerbread
man in a row,
not going to eat
them, no, no, no.
But they look so sweet from head
to toe, crunch, munch, oh, oh!.
Now we had three and
we take away one.
How many do we have left?
Two. Two gingerbread
men in a row,
not going to eat
them, no, no, no!
But they look so sweet
from head to toe.
Crunch, munch, oh, oh!
. Now we had two and
we take away one.
We have how many left?
One. One gingerbread
man in a row,
not going to eat
them, no, no, no!
But they look so good and
suite from head to toe,
crunch, munch, oh, oh!.
Now we had one and we take it
away, how many do we have left?
Zero? Now this one is just
a little bit different.
No gingerbread man in a row, was
going to eat them, no, no, no!
But they look so sweet from head
to toe, crunch, munch, oh, well!
All gone. Very good!
(Applause) You guys
did a great job.
»: There they go.
All right.
We had a dog in that
story, didn't we?
Who remembers the
name of that dog?
Dalmatian?
All right.
Good. So we are going
to sing an old classic
about where is my dog la, la,
la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, oh,, oh, where,
has my little dog gone,
aware where can he be?
With his tail cut short
and his ears cut long, oh,
where, oh, where can he be?
Now let's make it a girl dog.
Oh, where, oh, where
has my little dog gone?
Oh,, oh, where can she be?
With her ears cut short
and her tail cut long, oh,
where aware can she be?
Very good.
(Applause) All right.
It is time for our goodbye song.
And goodbye is just a little
way and the rest, you all know.
Goodbye friend, goodbye
friend, goodbye friend;
it's time to say goodbye.
» Thank you for coming to
story time with Laura Murray.
Give her a big hand.
(Applause) All right.
Okay. Very good!
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.